So, we have used the O state to avoid
inefficiency of the MSI protocol that
had to do with the memory,
getting unnecessary accesses that
could be satisfied by caches
that already have the data.
There is another inefficiency
that both MSI and MOSI have.
And that inefficiency is related
to thread private data, or
data that is only ever
accessed by a single thread.
And thread private data is for
example, all data in a single threaded
program will be thread private.
So if we have a four core processor
around four single threaded programs,
they never share any data.
All of the data in these
programs is like this.
Even when we have a parallel program,
we still have data such as for
example, the stacks of
the individual threads
that are still going to be
accessed only by a single thread.
And then efficiency occurs when
we read the data in a thread, and
then we write it, and this is really
the only thread accessing this data.
With both MSI and MOSI,
what's going to happen is the data
was invalid before we had it.
We read it.
We have a miss.
Now we get the data in the shared state.
When we want to write it, because
it's a shared state, we need to send
out an invalidation, and then we have
the block in the modified state.
And for every single block of data,
we have to do this.
In contrast,
if we had that uniprocessor,
the block would have a valid bit of 0,
we read it, we have a miss.
Now, the value bit becomes 1, and
then we have a hit when we write it, and
then we just change the dirty bit to 1,
so somehow the uniprocessor gets to do
a miss here and a hit here,
whereas to do MSI or
MOSI, we have to do a miss
followed by another bus request.
Granted, it doesn't carry data,
but still we have to wait for
the bus, send something
outside the ship and so on, so
this is still a lot slower
than just a cache hit.
And it's okay to pay the penalty for
having coherence if we're actually
sharing the data, because a uniprocessor
would not provide coherent behavior.
But here,
we actually have no sharing whatsoever.
So what we want to do is
avoid this invalidation, and
to do that, we introduce
a new state called exclusive.